do you have an average sex life let's
see how you stack up between the sheets
in your life you will kiss an average of
21 and a half people exchanging 278
types of bacteria per smooch and
spending two full weeks locking lips if
you're a man you'll lose your virginity
at sixteen point eight years old if
you're a woman you'll hold out a little
longer until you're seventeen point two
years old if you're a millennial you'll
have sex with eight partners over the
course of your life if you are a gen Xer
you'll have ten sexual partners and
twelve if you're a baby boomer whether
you're straight or gay won't affect how
much sex you have one poll found the
median number of sexual partners was six
for straight men straight women gay men
and gay women although if you're a woman
there's a seventeen point four percent
chance you've been with another woman as
opposed to a five point seven percent
chance if you're a man with another man
you'll have the most sex of your life
between the ages of 30 and 34 you'll
have 1836 orgasms if you're a woman and
4233 orgasms if you're a man how many of
those are self induced varies widely
there's a 61% chance you'll have a
one-night stand a 36 point five percent
chance you've had anal sex with a
heterosexual partner a 30% chance you
paid for sex if you're a man over 30
years old a 25% chance you'll cheat or
get cheated on a 14% chance you'll have
a threesome and a 2 to 3 percent chance
you'll engage in BDSM although there's a
20% chance it arouses you that
differential made the Fifty Shades of
Grey franchise 700 million dollars and
Counting and what about sex later in
life 53 percent of new seniors aged 64
to 75 are having sex while 26 percent of
the elderly age 75 to 85 are still
getting it on unfortunately rates of
both chlamydia and syphilis have nearly
tripled among seniors from the years
2000 to 2010 from your first kiss to
your last romp have fun out there and
don't let those seniors set the example
for safe sex